[موسيقى]
غاريث بيل يشاركوا في بطوله الجولف بايرن
ميونخ يقيله مسرب الاخبار والمدرسه اصعب
فتره الوسام هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها
لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد اعتزاله لاعب كره القدم سيشاركه غاريث
بيل في تحدي بروم للجولف وهو تحدي المجتمع
اي ترفيه يجمع اللاعبين المحترفين بالهوات
قبل ايام من انطلاق البطوله الرسميه بين
لن يكون وحيدا في هذه البطوله التي ستشهد
مشاركته ثنائي ليفربول
قرر نادي بايرن ميونخ الالماني اقاله
المدرب الحراس لديه توني تبلوفيتش وسبب هو
تسريبه المحادثات بين الطاقه التجريبي الى
اللاعبين واولهم خالد الفريق
الحارس الالماني المصاب نشر صوره له
معتوني على الانستغرام وارفقها برساله شكر
ودعم لمدرب الحراس السابق الذي بدا عمله
مع بايرن عام 2011 ومنحله الكثيرون الفضل
في المستوى العالي وجعله واحدا من افضل
الحراس في العالم
نبقى مع اخباري بايرن ميونخ حيث اثار
النجم سرجنا بغضبه مدربه مجلس زمان بعد
سفره الى باريس لحضور الاسبوع الماضي
بعدنا من البقاء مع الفريق والتحضيري
للمباراه المقبله خاصه ان باين قد تعادل
في الجوله الماضيه امام لايف زق وتنتظره
مواجهه مهمه ضد كولن في اول لقاءنا على
ملعب اليانز بعد منافسات كاس العالم وكان
جنابري قد نشر عبر حساب على الانستغرام
الصور له في اسبوع الموضه اعجبت الكثير من
المتابعين
[موسيقى]
كشف البريطاني الوسام الفورمولا 1 و بطل
العالم سبع مرات عن اسوء الفترات التي مرت
عليه في حياتها عندما كان صغيرا هملتهم
قال بان حياته في المدرسه كانت هي اصعب
وسبب هو تنمر الذي كان يتعرض له كما ان
بعض التلاميذ اعتدوا رمي بثمار الموز
بينما كان الاطفال الاكبر والاقوى يعتدون
عليه في احيان كثيره لكن وبعد سنوات طويله
يعد هاملتون الان اساق الوحيد من ذوي
البشره السمراء الذي توج بطلا للعالم في
سباقات الفورمولا 1
[موسيقى]